what I want to do in this video is write
the algebraic expressions that represent
the same thing that these statements are
saying so this first statement they say
the sum of negative 7 and the quantity 8
times X so the sum the sum so we're
going to have an addition here of
negative 7 of negative 7 and the
quantity 8 times X so the quantity 8
times X well that's just 8x so I can
just write 8x over there so it is
negative 7 plus 8x or you could view
this as the sum of negative 7 and the
quantity 8 times X let's do the next one
take the quantity negative 3 times X so
take the quantity negative 3 times X and
then add 1 and then add 1 so the
quantity negative 3 times X we can write
that as negative 3x and then we need to
add 1 to that so that's going to be plus
plus 1 now this one negative 6 plus
negative 6 plus so we can write negative
6 plus something the product of negative
1 and X so the product of negative 1 and
X that's just going to be negative 1 X
negative 1 X which is the same thing as
negative x so we can write this as
negative 6 plus negative X or we can
just write this this is the exact same
thing as negative 6 negative 6 minus X
and we are done